strong move there on that one-on-one
attack
he's got 15 points six of seven from the
field continuing
for the finish and then mitchell just
continuing to attack the paint
putting pressure on the interior defense
on his game here in this fourth quarter
on the road george continuing to
struggle
your best player is going to have to
step up and make plays step back three
good donovan mitchell
a deep shot now one of seven from
downtown
mitchell answers
[Music]
mitchell the drive the finish
they are really struggling to contain
mitchell
and they're basically putting him in
that pick and roll on every possession
and he is getting wherever he wants on
the floor seven with possession we
approach three minutes to play
and they're gonna go back to it they're
just gonna keep canard in this pick and
roll
mitchell the spin the scoop does he go
foul called i'm a little surprised and i
understand that canards play well but
i'm a little surprised that ty lue has
kept him in for this entire stretch
because
they are really struggling to contain
mitchell
and they're basically putting him in
that pick and roll on every possession
and he is getting wherever he wants on
the floor
donovan mitchell 41 points
his team up by seven
another category turnovers utah has just
four one in the second half
mitchell has scored 30
in the second half 43 overall 109 to 100
utah
12 to shoot switch now he's got canard
mitchell the drive the blow-by for
donovan mitchell